il y a deux ans emmanuel macron et est
élu président de la république
bienvenue françois xavier vallat vie
bonjour merci et bravo pour ce nouvel
horaire il s'en est passé depuis
beaucoup
il s'en est passé il sympa chaque jour
deux ans déjà deux ans et la vraie
question c'est qu'est ce qu'il s'est
réellement passé pour permettre de faire
face à tous les grands défis auxquels
notre pays est confronté
mon sentiment si vous me le demandez sur
ces deux ans et qu'on a perdu beaucoup
de temps dans une conjoncture économique
qui était plutôt favorable avec cette
dynamique que le président de la
république avait derrière lui je crois
qu'il aurait pu faire des réformes très
structurante pour tenter de proposer un
cap pour l'avenir de notre pays de nous
redonner confiance et malheureusement
rien de tout cela n'a eu lieu et nous
avons à la fois une les vols d'air
france et en avons la fois une révolte
sociale très forte sans que
malheureusement elle n'est été suscitée
par par des réformes d'ampleur mais la
france est devenue comme une sorte de
chantier en transformation qui ne peut
pas se faire sans qu'il ait conflit
détention en permanence mais où voyez
vous les grandes réformes structurelles
sur le je ne vais pas reprocher à
monsieur macron toutes les difficultés
que notre pays traverse dont il hérite
évidemment et qui sont le fait de bien
des majorités politiques qui l'ont
précédé il ne reste pas moins
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple sur la
question du déficit public est ce que
nous avons réussi à faire baisser la
dépense publique non est ce que nous
avons réformé l'organisation de l'état
nomades année mais comment vous
répondriez vous même et puis d'abord ne
m'obligez pas à le dire mais bien ou mal
fait emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
philippe on en fait formation
professionnelle et apprentissage réforme
la sncf prélèvement à la source
doublement des classes l'orim prime
d'activité très intéressant assurance
chômage
bientôt la décentralisation baisse
promise des impôts et puis tiens sur sur
les retraites que ce second est ce qu on
fait attention
est-ce qu'on pourrait revenir sur cette
île va revenir mais vos vies sur la de
fermat brûlant des vers non dit jean
pierre elkabbach lui une baisse des
impôts d'abord est-ce que la fiscalité a
baissé sans doute à la marge
malheureusement elle va repartir à la
hausse avec les dernières annonces du
président de la république
deuxièmement si vous baissez les impôts
sans faire baisser la dépense publique
vous êtes en train de préparer bien les
impôts de mire et alors vous vous
comment vous bell souriez les dépenses
publiques
elle dépend ça ne vous a pas échappé que
je suis candidat à l'élection européenne
pour une famille politique qui lors de
la dernière élection présidentielle
s'est présenté au suffrage avec le
courage d'un plan de réformes qui était
un plan extrêmement clair un plan global
dont on a pu dire qu'il était peut-être
trop dur mais qui avait le mérite en
tous les cas d'offrir des perspectives
claires pour faire en sorte qu enfin on
sorte de cette paralysie dont encore une
fois le président de la république a
hérité mais qu'il n'a rien fait pour
pouvoir guérif
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous en
sommes toujours au même point je reviens
sur les différents éléments que vous
avez évoquées effectivement la sncf a
été réformé c'était de toute façon
vendre gardant sa part le conte le cas
très bien que les français comprennent
que malheureusement mais je ne dis pas
ça pour m'en réjouir mon but n'est pas
de sauver le rôle d'un opposant absurde
ailleurs mais simplement je crois que
nous avons devant nous encore la
résolution des grands défis vous avez
encore trois ans au moins tendres mais
si le bilan de emmanuel macron
globalement été aussi catastrophique la
droite que vous représentez elle
caracolerait en tête et elle serait
appelée par l'opinion est ce que c'est
le cas je crois vraiment un jeu
d'illusions qui s'est entretenu pendant
ces deux dernières années où à la faveur
du en même temps et peut-être d'une
forme précisément de d'agitation qui
était plutôt de la communication de
l'hypercommunication que de l'action
réelle on a pu croire qu'il était en
train de se passer quelque chose et je
crois que nous avons eu malheureusement
dans ces deux dernières années à la fois
cette espèce de d'épuisement que crée
cette agitation perpétuelle sans que
malgré tout rien n'a été vraiment entre
eux puis sur le fond et je le redis
malheureusement sur tous ces grands
chantiers sur la sur la baisse de la
dépense publique sur la baisse de la
fiscalité sur la réorganisation de
l'état sur le fait de remédier en
profondeur à la crise et locatives que
notre pays connaît sur le fait de
pouvoir mettre fin à l'immigration
massive qui déstabilise notre société
c'est quand même un ancien ministre de
l'intérieur de monsieur mâcon qui nous a
averti qu' aujourd'hui nous sommes côte
à côte et que demain peut-être nous
serons face à face sur les grands
chantiers maintenant vague rien n'a été
entrepris ici et encore une fois il
avait eu le génie de révision précise
que pour diane entre leurs deux jours
que pour dire l'ampleur de notre
responsabilité vis à ses congés elle
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le rassemblement de marine
le pen est en tête
si les élections présidentielle avait
lieu aujourd'hui
et quelle serait votre choix marine le
pen ou emmanuel macron que vous venez de
critiquer mes jeux
tout le monde travaille et de me battre
pour essayer d'offrir une véritable
alternative parce que je crois que
d'accord sur mes choix en ce moment sur
les us que je peux terminer ma réponse
monsieur vous dérange pas oui je crois
que ce qui est très important il faut
que les français le comprennent c'est
que nous n'avons pas d'avenir dans cette
alternative qui n'en est pas une entre
populisme et progressistes et toute la
stratégie de monsieur macron consiste à
la voir que madame le pen face à lui eh
bien nous allons faire échouer ces
stratégies travers ce qu'il faut offrir
aux français une véritablement mort et
nous n'avons pas envie de revivre ce
débat dont le nord qui ne peut conduire
à mon avis nul c'est une manière ne pas
me répondre mais bien sûr que si c'est
la réponse qu'a page 2 qui
idéologiquement vous le sentez le plus
proche là vous vous êtes en train de
jouer ce jeu que je crois mortifère part
de l'est moins pour notre pays qui
consiste à dire qu'on est contraint de
choisir son camp entre d'un côté le déni
de réalité que monsieur macron persiste
à entretenir et de le coter
l'impuissance gens-là collège dans le
gard drôme l'illusion est le mensonge
parce qu'autant les attraits et demi
pour cent dans les sondages comment on
peut prétendre être l'alternative
possible pour le pays
mais d'abord ça ne vous aura pas échappé
que la dernière fois que vous avez reçus
nous étions à 8 ou 9 % dans les sondages
aujourd'hui on nous on nous met à 15 et
demi ou 15 dans les sondages pour
l'élection européenne en quelques
semaines nous avons une belle dynamique
derrière nous et nous allons
effectivement je le dis avec beaucoup de
sérieux parce que c'est la raison de mon
engagement
nous allons offrir une vraie alternative
dans cette élection européenne parce
qu'il faut parler d'europe et je crois
que nos mirettes élections européennes
on ne peut déjà pas se réduire à cette
espèce de choix absurdes qui
consisterait à se laisser enfermer dans
un deuxième tour mais à partir de quel
score est de combien de députés vous
estimez que votre mission sera accompli
notre mission sera accomplie lorsque
nous aurons réussi à susciter la
confiance du plus rien aux normes
générales y faire peser au sein du rpt
et de la précision
je me donne le même conseil que je donne
à mes étudiants il faut faire le mieux
possible et tout point que je gagnerais
que nous gagnerons ensemble avec cette
équipe qui m'entoure avec agnès evren
avec arnaud danjean tout point que nous
gagnerons ce sera un élu de plus pour
faire entendre la voix des français non
c'est ce que vous dites mais
généralement mais vous me répondez pas
précisément mais parce que je peux pas
vous dire que je me satisferait d'un
score je chercherai toujours affaire à
un moment vous disiez 15% à un moment
vous avez dit veut pour ça moi je n'ai
jamais je ne me suis jamais fixé dans
paris match vous avez dit peut-être 15 %
en janvier on sait jamais fixé de
le point limite je crois qu'il faut
faire de son mieux et je vais faire de
mon mieux en tous les cas pour le reste
c'est pour vous le 26 mai françois que
sa famille est ce qu'il s'agit de
renforcer l' influence le poids de la
france en europe dans le monde ou de
faire battre et de sanctionner les
manuels macron non il s'agit pas
sanctionné véniel macron il s'agit pas
non plus de faire barrage aux extrêmes
la seule question qui compte c'est
comment faire entendre la voix de la
france
effectivement demain au sein du
parlement européen et je crois qu'il
faut surtout peu il faut surtout pas à
manquer cette élection au motif d'une
sorte de mise en scène artificielle le
sujet fondamental c'est le sujet de
savoir comment la france va pouvoir
obtenir de nos partenaires européens
la refondation de l'europe dont nous
avons tellement besoin les chocs
économiques et commerciales chacun des
profondes et l'europe pour la relancer
on entend le mayen emmanuel macron on
entend la têt lilloise on entend jérôme
bord de la route
oui ben abdallah de la wii monsieur
l'ordinateur comme bach dollar si vous
me le permettez fête de famille
politique qui nous a expliqué au cours
des dernières années qu'il fallait des
faire l'europe qu'il fallait faire
exploser la construction européenne pour
retrouver plus de liberté nous ne le
croyons pas nous croyons pas que nous
serons plus forts si nous sommes isolés
ce que nous croyons en revanche c'est
qu'il faut construire une europe qui
permettent de renforcer nos pays dans la
mondialisation plutôt que de les
fragiliser au grand rendez-vous
stanislas guerre inique et le numéro un
du parti en marche a annoncé et où a
demandé au président de la république
d'intervenir à ce que vous soyez choqué
que emmanuel macron interviennent dans
la campagne pour les européennes
je crois que macro intervient déjà dans
la campagne pour l'élection européenne
mais qu'ils le fassent surprise qu'ils
le fassent
ce serait le signe de quoi qui
s'intéresse à l'europe qu'il veut
défendre la liste où les grandes idées
ou la vision qu'il l'est de l'europe
moi ce qui m'importe c'est pas d'abord
la question des personnes c'est d'abord
la question du projet est ce que je
regrette profondément c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
du côté de la république en marche on
ait aucune transparence la république en
marche ne nous dit pas quel est son
projet il sera des volets seulement 9
mai c'est à dire quinze jours avant le
scrutin
ce qui me paraît le signe d'une
impréparation relativement préoccupante
il intervient à ce que vous dites c'est
normal et qui défendent lui comme la
plupart des stratèges malgré un jour il
le président en a référé à
l'intervention en trop le président la
république est tout à fait fondé à
intervenir dans le débat démocratique je
ne lui reprocherait pas la question
c'est quel est le cap que la république
en marche veut donner à l'action
européenne au cours des prochaines
années et nous ne le savons toujours pas
et je crois que ça n'allait pas très
sérieux ce n'est pas non plus très
respectueux de ce qu'est cette élection
c'est à dire de la nécessité d'un bon de
relire les discours des manuels mâcon
pour savoir quelle est la vision de
l'europe que sa liste va décliner ou
dessiner malheur si dans ce cas sa
vision de l'europe c'est celle du
discours de la sorbonne il discourt
d'athènes
ce sera très intéressant effectivement
qu'il la propose de manière claire dans
cette élection européenne
parce que je crois qu'elle ne correspond
pas du tout aux aspirations des français
dans ses discours le président de la
république n'était que je manquais est
ce que demandent les français que vous
avez l'art de danser l'endroit rôle
président de la république nous a
expliqué qu'il fallait
d'une certaine manière transférer notre
souveraineté à l'échelle européenne
moi ce que j'entends de la part des
français tous les jours sur le terrain
parce que ça fait trois mois que nous
sommes en campagne tous les jours au
contact des français
ce que j'entends de la part des français
c'est qu'ils ont besoin d'une europe qui
retrouve le sens de la démocratie c'est
à dire d'une europe qui renforce
la souveraineté renforcer notre capacité
on va prendre deux trois exemples et il
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé pendant
le week end et flambée de violences
entre israël et le hamas et le jihad
islamique à gaza
il ya eu des tirs qui ont été condamnés
par le président de la république s'est
tenu les par des tweets etc
l'europe ne dit rien vous vous n'avez
rien dit nous nous disons évidemment
avec mais avec du retard mais vous dit
rien bien sûr que s'il prenait 6 leur
deuxième en ce moment en arabie séoudite
mohamed el monsieur le gall est en train
de de multiplier les décapitations et
crucifixions et d'enfermer les
responsables des droits de l'homme et de
la femme dans son pays
silence absolu pourquoi vous avez un
silence monsieur elkabbach au revoir
n'aura pas échappé que je suis candidat
à l'élection européenne
mon rôle n'est pas de au nom il était
encore au père rôle n'est pas de
hamburgers et internationales en
permanence
il est très clair que l'union européenne
doit jouer un rôle fondamental pour
faire enfin valoir
l'attachement qu'elle a au principe de
défense des droits de l'homme et que
pendant trop longtemps c'est vrai nous
avons baissé la gare nous avons baissé
la tête
il n'est pas question d'entretenir cette
fragilité coupable plus longtemps et si
on parle de la question de l'arabie
saoudite il est très clair que sur la
question par exemple industriel et
commercial
il faut absolument que nous puissions de
nouveau nous doter d'une stratégie parce
que c'est cette absence de traite de
stratégie qui nous rend aussi fragile
pour défendre notre attachement à notre
stratégie
à quoi ressemblerait votre stratégie
pourquoi ya pas stratégie aujourd'hui
parce que j'aurais à toi le rottweiler
et aujourd'hui nous avons sur la
question industrielle par exemple une
doctrine de la concurrence on a vu à
l'occasion du dossier alsthom si mince
que cette doctrine de la concurrence
elle nous fragilise le lieu nous
renforcer il faut enfin que nous
puissions faire en sorte de défendre une
stratégie
par exemple en matière d'industrie de la
défense et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui nous avons mal et vous
arrêterez les ventes d'armes dans la
plupart des pays où par exemple l'arabie
séoudite entre le cas il faut faire en
sorte que nous puissions affirmer notre
indépendance en mai et ça veut dire la
réponse
cette indépendance elle passe par le
fait de construire une vraie stratégie
industrielle
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de capacité
de faire rayonner notre autonomie
stratégique parce que notre industrie
perd peu à peu sa capacité
d'indépendance ce qui veut dire que sur
la question de la défense
nous commençons à dépendre de grandeur
quelques généralités
dans une heure et demie 6 nouvelles
méthodes le premier ministre reçoit
syndicats élus locaux associations etc
pour évoquer des décisions qui seraient
concrètes et rapides sur l'apprentissage
l'environnement et l'écologie le premier
ministre proposerait un pacte productif
de plein emploi pour l'horizon 2025
est ce que vous dit chiche et vous y
participer qu'est ce que ça veut dire un
pacte productif pour le plein emploi
vous me reprochez de produire des
généralités mais alors là pour le coup
on est en plein dedans monsieur
elkabbach si vous me le permettez un
pacte productif ça veut dire quoi
moi ce que je crois c'est
qu'effectivement il faut qu'on se
remette à produire c'est la question de
ces stratégies industrielles que
j'évoquais à l'instant mais se remettre
à produire ça veut dire d'abord libérer
les entreprises qui sont asphyxiés
aujourd'hui par une fiscalité qui est la
plus élevée au monde
nous avons les prélèvements fiscaux et
sociaux les plus élevés au monde et
l'oms et les handicaps l'aco dit c'est
du baratin sens des mots sincères plan
la faiseuse de mettre autour d'une table
des gens qui viennent discuter il faut
maintenant agir
le premier ministre et premier mise d'un
président de la république lui-même été
ministre de françois hollande
ils sont aux responsabilités depuis
maintenant sept ans si on fait
l'addition de toutes ces années a cumulé
nous connaissons ils connaissent mieux
que personne les problèmes de la france
il est temps d'agir plutôt que de parler
ya sur un point vous pourrez peut-être
dire merci à emmanuel macron directement
c'est grâce à lui que cette entrée en
politique au passage non je suis élu de
plans du milieu avait voulu du local
vous ne pouvez pas imaginez vous serez
les viets de liste des républicains soit
je sais pas si je dois lui dire merci ça
je fais pas ça spécialement par plaisir
j'aime beaucoup mon métier j'enseigne la
philosophie c'est un métier passionnant
je m'engage dans cette campagne parce
que je crois qu'il faut absolument que
nous offrions cette alternative qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans le débat
vers père est le seul à devoir national
et je m'engage dans cette campagne parce
que ça annexée par les styles semba moi
ou de notre famille pour le fausse
humilité c'est notre famille politique
qui a assez tôt qu en aucun cas une
fausse humilité mais je crois que nous
avons c'est vrai une responsabilité
c'est à notre famille politique de
dépasser les erreurs qu'elle a pu faire
par le passé quelques questions
auxquelles vous me répondait rapidement
il est question de supprimer des niches
fiscales pas pour les ménages
ce sont autant de milliers de dérogation
est ce que vous êtes favorable avec
lesquels il faut en finir le travail
qu'est ce que ça veut dire supprimer des
niches fiscales ça veut dire tout
simplement augmenter les impôts
soyons clairs les niches fiscales ne
sont pas une manière biwolé maintenair
d'échapper à l'impôt belle kelly sont
manière pour l'état d'organiser la
dépense publique la question c'est
quelles sont les niches fiscales qui
sont potentiellement inutile mais cette
question là ne nous dédouanera pas d'un
vrai travail pour faire des économies et
faire faire des économies à l'état
c'est je crois à l'urgence absolue si
nous ne voulons pas en rester dans cette
situation d' asphyxie fiscale mais si
nous ne voulons pas continuer de léguer
à ceux qui nous suivront la dette
accumulée sur la transition écologique
comment et avec quoi et avec qui la
finançait la transition écologique c'est
d'abord une question de avec l'iran la
violence qu'on l'a on l'a on l'a on la
construit d'abord et ça c'est un
magnifique sujet européen on la
construit d'abord en rééquilibrant la
mondialisation aujourd'hui nous avons
une mondialisation débridée qui fait la
catastrophe écologique que nous
traversons aujourd'hui nous avons une
mondialisation qui correspond à une
forme de terrorisme à l'échelle
internationale où tout se passe comme si
l'industrie devait se faire en asie et
nous allions produire uniquement des
services et des loisirs
mais je crois que nous ne pouvons plus
vivre dans ce bar est pas répandue qui a
produit la cathédrale à dublin sont
aujourd'hui donc c'est moins une
question de financement
s'il s'agissait de dépenser de l'argent
public on serait déjà un paradis
écologique qu'une manière justement de
reconstruire notre capacité de produire
ce que nous consommons pour rééquilibrer
la mondialisation et ça c'est un très
grand défi pour l'europe là la france a
décidé où le président de la république
a ordonné la fermeture de quatre
centrales à charbon en france
est ce que vous demandez si vous êtes
élu européen à tous les européens aient
compris l allemagne pollueuses d'en
faire autant au moins là dessus bien sûr
ça suppose qu'on se mette tous d'accord
sur le fait qu'effectivement il faut
continuer de garder notre capacité de
production d'énergie nucléaire qui est
une production décarbonée saada
effectivement vous défendez le nucléaire
nous avons beaucoup de villes nucléaire
et des incapacités qui lui permet à
celles qui nous permet d'être
aujourd'hui les producteurs d'une
énergie qui est la plus écologique au
monde parce qu'elle est la moins
carbonées et la moins chère est
d'ailleurs il faudrait à présent savoir
ce qu'on pense il faudrait savoir ce
qu'en pensent ceux qui effectivement sur
la liste de manoise eux représentent une
idéologie une écologie parfois très
idéologique qui a conduit souvent au
contraire de ce qu'elle pouvait en soi
de rugby
annoncé ici l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité en juin tout de suite
après l'élection européenne d'ailleurs
de 5,9 pour cent au moins est ce que
vous avez le moyen d'empêcher cette
augmentation du prix de l'électricité
il faut empêcher cette augmentation est
il faut je commence en mettant fin par
exemple à cette folie là aussi très
idéologique de l'éolien qui contribue à
faire monter le prix de l'électricité
alors qu'il ne contribue en rien à
vendre à notre langue auditer les âges
et les 6% st gall n'est pas question est
faux on peut ne pas vous ne vous dites
pas que si on retarde on paye de toute
façon ce qui est certain c'est que il
faut penser les choses dans leur
globalité et là encore donc avec un euro
a pesé on peut pas imposer c'était la
même chose avec l'augmentation du prix
des carburants
on peut pas imposer de nouvelles
augmentations de coûts de nouvelles
augmentations de charges aux français
sans penser une baisse de la fiscalité
de manière globale parce qu'aujourd'hui
je le vois tous les jours sur le terrain
beaucoup de français travaillent et ne
parviennent pas à s'en sortir beaucoup
de français qui se donnent beaucoup de
peine n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux
bouts et on n'a pas le droit d'imposer
toujours plus de charges et de et de
poids à ces français de kaki talent et
quitta les désespérés vous répétez
volontiers peut-être avec raison je ne
sais pas la civilisation européenne avec
ses racines judéo chrétiennes et en
danger qu'est ce qui la menace
ce qui la menace c'est notre incapacité
à faire face à tous les défis qu'on
évoque à l'instant ce qui l'amena c'est
aussi le communautarisme qui traversent
notre société on le voit avec le livre
de jérôme fourquet la france archipel on
voit bien à quel point ce que décrit
jérôme fourquet c'est une france fait
d'une pluralité de communauté qui
s'éloigne ladoire qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qui l'a menacée 90 un pardon
je reviens sur ce fait précis quand un
chauffeur de bus refuse d'ouvrir la
porte de son bus à une jeune fille parce
qu'elle parlait des lieux elles étaient
deux voilà ce qui signifie qu'elle
fumait il ya une enquête et inter il ya
une enquête interne malheureusement sans
avoir la vérité que tout le monde sait
très bien que le communautarisme touche
directement notre société si ce fait est
avéré je suis d'accord avec vous il faut
aller au bout de cette enquête
mais si ce fait est avéré il est l'un
des symptômes de plus de cette crise qui
ferait presque comme la grande bretagne
la france devrait déclarer les frères
musulmans organisation terroriste comme
la grande bretagne la france devra
sortir de la naïveté en matière de lutte
contre l'islamisme radical est sans
doute déclaré effectivement toutes les
organisations terroristes comme étant
ses adversaires immédiats comme la
grande bretagne elle devrait aussi
réagir en faisant appliquer sa culture
ses principes
je crois que je le voyais récemment lors
d'un déplacement
en grande bretagne quand vous devez les
citoyens britanniques vous devez adhérer
un certain nombre de la renaissance de
culte interdit ce qui ressemble aux
frères musulmans et tout ce qui s'en est
ce pire de deux trois questions très
rapide le 1er juin
vous serez élu député européen est-ce
que vos destin politique s'arrêtera là
bas à strasbourg est ce que le parlement
européen serait le tombeau de vos
ambitions fortes et légitimes de vos
ambitions nationales
moi ma seule et unique ambition jean
pierre elkabbach je le dis sans aucune
fausse humilité pour reprendre votre
expression
ma seule et unique ambition c'est de
servir d'être aussi utile que je
pourrais à mon pays dans les années qui
viendront à cette europe dans laquelle
nous avons besoin d'agir efficacement
parce que nous sommes à un carrefour et
j'avais là que le mandat qui s'annoncent
le mandat du parlement européen va être
un mandat décisif et j'espère pouvoir
apporter l'état par une tribu sion au
cours de tables malgré étape par étape
vous construisez votre destin national
petit à petit j'ai petit à petit
l'oiseau fait son nid
je n'ai jamais fait de calculs sur
l'avenir j'ai jamais fait de billard à
trois bandes et je crois que ce qui a
tué la politique c'est cette situation
de d'ambitions individuelles qu'on dise
qu'on les lui redonnera sud est ce qu'en
dit c'est le fait se mettre au service
de quelques quelques mots dé tous les
ambitieux l'oiseau fait son nid et quand
je parle de l'oiseau je prends de bel
ami
merci d'être venus merci à vous deux
journées